[applause]
Kevin Gibbs: Great.
Thanks a lot, Mike.
Well, I want to talk about
one more thing about SDC
before I move on,
and that's integration.
Now, if any of you have worked
with web services before,
you know that there are
a lot of different types
and a lot of different formats,
and integrating
is not always easy.
To help with that,
something that we've done
is we've worked with a number
of Enterprise partners
to create connectors for SDC,
that make it easy to work
with the Enterprise
software packages
that you already have.
There are already
50 connectors available,
and if there's an
Enterprise software package
you're using that doesn't
have a connector,
we have
another set of partners
who are eager to help out,
can help you create a solution.
Now, let's recap about
what I've already talked about
this evening really briefly.
I've talked about some
major features for App Engine.
One, we have the ability to
purchase additional resources.
We talked about
the cron support for App Engine.
We talked about the ability
to import
large amounts of data
and the ability to access data
behind the firewall.
Now, we think
all of these things together
make App Engine
a more viable platform
for more developers
and more people
who are building applications,
but we still have
a promise to keep to you.
When I was here last year,
one year to this day,
I promised that Python
was just the first language
for App Engine,
the first runtime language
that we would support.
Thus tonight,
I'm really excited to announce
our early look
at Java language support
for App Engine.
[applause]
Now--
Now, what's up
with the early look?
You guys might be wondering.
Now, the reason
for the early look
is that we feel that the support
we're launching right now
is not yet complete.
We've got a lot of details
that we need to work out,
and things that we need to make
run a little more smoothly.
Particularly, due to the nature
of the environment,
we know a lot of software
that you're used to
and a lot of frameworks
you've used before
may need some slight adjustments
to work properly
on App Engine.
Thus, we want to learn
what those things are
and get your help to fix them,
so that we can make App Engine
work better for you
and for everyone else,
so that's why we're giving you
this early access
to the product,
to get that feedback,
and get the product on track.
Now, with all of that said,
I think what we're launching
to you tonight
is pretty impressive.
For the first time,
we've given you
an in-to-in solution,
a runtime, a Java runtime
for App Engine,
an Eclipse plugin
for the Eclipse IDE,
and integrated
Google Web Toolkit support
for your UI.
Altogether,
this allows you--
[applause]
Thanks.
Altogether,
this allows you
to build a client
and the server together,
in one integrated
development experience,
using a single language,
and a single, seamless
application that you create.
We think that's pretty cool.
So tonight,
for the rest of the night,
I'm going to take you through
our early look at Java support
for App Engine.
I'm going to take you through,
initially,
a demonstration that we built
using GuestBook,
an application
that just allows you
to quickly enter some stuff.
Andrew is going to take you
through that demo
and how we built
the GuestBook app.
Then I'm also going to
bring on some partners
who've built
some real-world apps
using App Engine,
Google Web Toolkit,
and other things,
so that you can see how
this can be--
you could use this yourself
to accomplish
some other things.
But to get started,
let me take you through
the Java runtime support
for App Engine.
Now, our Java runtime support
for App Engine
allows you to utilize
all the APIs
that you already have available
on App Engine.
That includes things like
our scalable data store,
which is based on BigTable,
not SQL,
things like memcache,
our serving architecture,
and also all of the existing
management tools
you've been using,
such as our
administration console,
the billing support
I mentioned earlier,
and all of that.
It makes it easy for you
to build and deploy
web applications.
But there's something
that I think
is particularly interesting
about our Java support.
We built our Java support
around Servlets
and the web.xml standard.
These are the standard ways
of building web apps in Java,
so what that means for you,
is if you've ever built
a web app in Java before,
you probably already know
how to build a web app
for Google App Engine.
It's the same thing
you're used to,
written in the same way.
Now, the other major detail
about our Java runtime
support for App Engine,
is that it is a full
Java 1.6 JVM.
Now, what does that mean?
That means two important things.
One, it means that
we're running byte code
on the server,
not your source code.
You only send us
your compiled application.
Two, it means that because
we're running byte code,
App Engine's
Java runtime support
can run other languages
that compile to Java byte code,
things like JavaScript,
Ruby, Groovy,
and other projects.
Now, I should make it clear--
just because we can
run those languages
in the Java runtime support,
doesn't mean
that your applications
written in those languages
will just work automatically.
There's still a lot of work
to be done with integration,
to make sure everything
runs smoothly,
particularly with
our serving infrastructure
and our security infrastructure
on App Engine,
many frameworks will need to be
adjusted slightly.
We also have a white list
of JRE classes
that are available,
which may sometimes result
in changes.
However, that's why
we're launching this
early to you now,
so we can get your help
in making sure everything
does work smoothly
on App Engine.
Now, our overall goal
with our entry in Java support
is to give you tools
that compliment
your existing workflow,
how you already
build applications.
And one thing we know
about a lot of Java developers
is that you use IDEs
to get these applications built.
So as I mentioned earlier,
that's why I'm excited tonight
to announce
the Google plugin for Eclipse.
The Google plugin for Eclipse
integrates every step
of the application development,
from creating
and managing a project
to doing local testing
and debugging,
and to finally
deploying to App Engine.
It even integrates
using Google Web Toolkit
to create your front-end UI,
which I'll talk about
a little bit later.
Now, we think this is great
for productivity.
You're programming
just in one language,
in one familiar IDE
that you're
already comfortable with.
And because App Engine
is always free to get started,
it means that anyone
can download this SDK
and start building
an application right away.
Now, I want you to know
one other thing, though.
Although we are launching
the Google plugin for Eclipse,
we're in no way tied
to this Eclipse support.
We're also providing you
with robust, stand-alone tools
that you can use
to build applications,
and that means that you can work
with other IDEs
like IntelliJ or Visual Studio,
or you can work with tools
on the command line.
Now, one more aspect about
our Java support for App Engine
that I'm particularly
excited about
is our support for standards.
Our Java support
for App Engine
is 100% standard spaced.
Now, what does that mean?
That means two key things.
One, it means
that if you choose,
you can build an application
on our early look at Java
support for App Engine
that does not use
a single proprietary API.
Through these standards
for everything that we do,
including specifying
your web application
for accessing HTTP resources,
and even for working
with our datastore,
which is based on BigTable,
there is a standard
that you can use
backed by a JSR and sign
for building your application.
For our datastore in particular,
we're supporting
the Java persistence API
and the Java data
object standards.
And that means that if
you build an application
with these standard APIs,
your same application
can work with BigTable
and a SQL server easily.
Now, the second detail
about our standard support
is that if you choose to build
your application
to all of these standards,
it makes it easy for you
to run your application
elsewhere,
because these same standard APIs
work in any other
Servlet container.
That means that you can build
an application on App Engine,
and without changing
the line of code
or making any significant
modifications,
you can run that application
on premise...
behind your firewall.
You're not locked in
to using our cloud.
So, with that,
if you're like me,
you're probably itching
to actually see
a demo of this,
and see how it all works.
So for that,
I'd like to call up
Andrew Bowers,
the product manager at Google,
and he's
going to step you through
creating a GuestBook application
using our Eclipse integration
and App Engine.
Thank you, Andrew.